bon je pars demain à paris oui comme
chaque année ludovic rochette prépare sa
venue au congrès des maires de vacances
prévues comme un rendez vous avec
emmanuel macron le président avait
promis de faire le déplacement
sauf qu'à la place le maire de brognon a
reçu cette invitation à l'elysée alors
voilà l'invitation que j'ai reçu de la
part du président de la république je
n'irai pas parce que je considère que la
place du président de république c'est
au sein du congrès c'est pas la verse
parce que c'est le signe peut-être un
peu maladroit d'une recentralisation
alors qu'on a besoin décentralisation à
brognon petite commune de 312 habitants
l'élu se plaint de la baisse des
financements
il pensait pourtant qu emmanuel macron
allait changer les choses
j'ai voté manu maquereau en deuxième
tour et pas du tout par défaut c'est que
je me suis dit entre les deux tours qui
se passait peut-être quelque chose et
qu'il fallait lui laisser sa chance
lord a passé une année de déception on a
envie que nos territoires et spir moi
j'ai envie ici les projets avancent qu
en face cette route qu'en face
l'accessibilité de la mairie court face
aux équipements sportifs bien là ça
devient compliqué les moindres
investissements devienne un casse tête
budgétaire assez que le terrain ne
donnent plus trop envie de faire du
sport là ne serait ce que pour rénover
ce terrain de sport un coup comme ça
c'est 90 euros la commune à la fin elle
va devoir mettre à peu près 30 35 euros
parce qu'il existe encore des aides de
l'état la région du département
mais la question c'est de savoir pendant
combien de temps nous aurons encore les
moyens de mettre ses 30 35 mille euros
cette question du manque de moyens sera
au coeur du congrès des maires
aujourd'hui